ce matin les salariés de france entière
sont plus que jamais au combat pour
défendre leur outil de travail
alors ils vendent leur journal
directement au public et des abonnements
à tarif réduit pour le mois car au delà
de novembre
l'avenir du groupe antilles guyane est
incertain placée en redressement
judiciaire le 25 juin
france antilles sera de nouveau devant
le tribunal de commerce dans cinq
semaines
si mercredi la ministre d outre-mer à
afficher le soutien du gouvernement et
annoncé des aides à l'étude pour la fin
d'année
rien encore de concret pour sauver
l'activité n'ont pour le moment puisque
on a une date à fin novembre au tribunal
c'est bien effectivement que l'état
montre son engagement mais effectivement
concrètement pour nous ç'a changé à
notre situation en fait
la ministre propose l'échelonnement des
dettes sociales et fiscales et des aides
spécifiques sont envisageables aide au
fret aide au portage ou encore à
l'innovation
mais le déficit du groupe france
antilles se creuse d'environ 500 mille
euros par mois ses ventes
8000 quotidien environ un jour de
semaine en martinique
25000 le week-end peuvent impérativement
augmenter de même que les recettes
publicitaires
actuellement en baisse
nos ventes publicitaires ainsi que nos
ventes sur la partie du fusion sur la
partie antilles guyane
est-ce que c'est faisable ou pas sa
structure actuellement c'est compliqué
mais je perds pas espoir
est ce que la vente d'abonnements web
ça peut vous sauver en tout cas il
faudrait pas multiplier cette fois par 5
en bourse en mai poids trois fois quatre
le nombre d'abonnés que l'on a
actuellement seule une offre de reprise
a été déposé un privé trente et un
salariés seulement seraient repris sur
alors cette semaine l'administrateur
judiciaire à relancer la procédure
les lecteurs assidus ne connaissent pas
tous ces détails
il imagine qu'une issue positive au
chant arrivé un an et demi c'était raté
les caves des problèmes tout le monde la
mairie la main à la pâte et maintenant
c'est le jour là alors il faut tout le
monde met la main à la peau mais qu'est
ce que ça représente pour vous ce
journal
c'est l'avis de laventie mika je connais
journal depuis je suis tout petit alors
quoi c'est difficile d'envisager qu'il
n'y ait pas un quotidien qui parle de la
martinique mais qui parle de tout sur
lamartine aussi bien la vie associative
le monde politique
l'atv les activités sportives et c'est
un lien c'est un lien social
quelle que soit la forme ce soit la
forme papier ou la forme internet ce
lien-là du quotidien il est impératif
c'est dire qu'on loue ces pros c'est pas
simplement une dimension économique
il ya une dimension aussi humaine la
nouvelle clôture des offres est fixée au
8 novembre prochain